been accused of sort of more like
copying uh other people's writings I
know I say this every now and again on
the show but this might be this might be
it this might actually be it this might
be the most insane thing ever uttered on
cable news this is absolutely
extraordinary this is a guy by the name
of Matt Egan on CNN and he's explaining
a bit about her plagiarism Scandal or
was it actually plagiarism listen to
Matt these plagiarism allegations uh
where Claud and gay has had to issue
Corrections um multiple Corrections now
we should note that um claudon gay has
not been accused of stealing anyone's
ideas in any of her writings uh she's
been accused of sort of a more like uh
copying uh other people's writings
without attribution so it's been more
sloppy attribution than stealing
anyone's ideas but nonetheless you you
put all of that together I'm sorry we
have to throw back to that one can we
throw back that that is just incredible
she didn't steel ideas she just copied
and pasted can we do oneism allegations
uh where claudian gay has had to issue
Corrections um multiple Corrections now
multiple times we should note that um
claudon gay has not been accused of
stealing anyone's ideas What She's
accused of U she's been accused of sort
of more like copying uh other people's
writings without attribution so it's
been more sloppy attribution than
stealing anyone's
uff the way they carry water for these
people you do not hate journalists
enough you really don't the corporate
press as my friend Michael malice always
says the corporate press is the enemy of
the people that is the most absurd she
didn't steal she just
stole